movie bloopers are a lot of fun plain
and simple
film fans love to watch actors flub and
considering the way they make themselves
and their co-stars laugh when it happens
actors clearly love bloopers two
filmmakers on the other hand may not
love them quite as much every time an
actor makes a mistake it delays the
shoot just a little and time is money
and every so often they're forced to
deal with a truly world-class mess-up a
mistake that caused the production big
money due to property damage and
personal injury 7 Brad Pitt suffered a
nasty injury on the set of seven during
one scene they called for him to chase
his suspect in the rain he slipped and
smashed his hand into a windshield
severing attendant director David
Fincher mentions on the film's DVD
commentary the pitch showed him his
wound which was so severe he could see
the white of the bone making the best of
a bad situation
Fincher managed to incorporate Pitt's
injury into the story of seven by having
the script rewritten to have Pitt's
character suffer an injury in the line
of duty
it added time and expense to the
production schedule but it was probably
a lot cheaper to explain why one of the
film's main characters was suddenly
wearing a cast
then simply delaying shooting long
enough for Pitt to recover still it
didn't solve the problem completely like
most movies 7 was shot out of sequence
so an earlier scene filmed after Pitt's
injury required the actor to hold his
bad hand in his pocket or behind his
back Skyfall according to writer and
filmmaker Charlie Line the 2012 James
Bond adventure Skyfall had to deal with
some unplanned expenses because star
Daniel Craig wore a pair of leather
gloves at the wrong moment as line told
the story via Twitter which he heard
from someone who worked on the film
Craig asked director Sam Mendes if he
could wear a pair of leather gloves in a
particular scene Mendes agreed and the
cast and crew got down to work filming a
sequence in which a bad guy gets bonds
gun away from him only to find he can't
fire it because it has a fingerprint
scanner it will only work for Bond as in
micro demo sensitive the grip and coded
to your palm prints only you can fire it
months later in the editing Bay a
production assistant noticed a problem
then how was bond ever gonna fire at
wearing gloves and so silence falls
across the room after considering the
costs of reshooting the scene the
filmmakers decided it would be cheaper
although still quite expensive to
digitally remove the gloves from Craig's
hands for the entire sequence
he watched the scene now honest to god
you can see
one has these ridiculously pudgy hands
he has these like mr. blobby hands
because in every single frame he was
wearing these thick leather gloves that
have now been painted over with Kraig
tone hands the hateful eight to play the
crafty outlaw Daisy donggu and Quentin
Tarantino's the hateful eight Jennifer
Jason Leigh had to learn how to play the
guitar the lucky actress got to learn on
the same one she'd strum in the film a
vintage Martin guitar dating to the 19th
century loaned to the movie by the
Martin guitar museum Lee's big guitar
playing moment on screen was all planned
out while she was playing co-star Kurt
Russell was supposed to grab it the
scene would cut and the Martin would be
traded out for a cheaper prop guitar
which Russell would smash when the
cameras started to roll again
but that isn't what happened instead
Russell grabbed the real Martin from Lee
and smashed it later told Billboard Kurt
felt terrible he had no idea Justice
League sometimes it's not the actor who
goofs up it's the studio responsible for
the movie and then they have to fork out
the cash to make things right Warner
Brothers had to reassemble the cast of
Justice League in the summer of 2017 for
some crucial reshoots
henry cavill who plays superman was
among those summoned but there was a
problem he'd grown a mustache for his
next role in the sixth Mission
Impossible movie and was contractually
obligated to keep it until mi6 was
finished filming the facial hair
scheduling snafu left Justice League's
visual effects technicians with the job
of digitally removing Superman's
mustache effects expert Dave fleet told
Business Insider it could cost millions
we would need to build a 3d model of the
face and then shade the surface of the
skin to look realistic we would then
need to track the 3d model to the
movement of his head and potentially
reanimate his mouth got to go it makes
you look like
the Avengers Marvel superhero team isn't
the only Avengers in pop culture
there's also V Avengers a 1960s British
spy TV series the 1998 film adaptation
starring Ray finds in uma thurman was a
critical and commercial bomb but the
movie made headlines for another type of
detonation while the crew filled an
explosion for the movie a few rope
sparks drifted away and hit the roof of
the studio starting a fire that was
definitely not part of the plan a set
worth a reported 1.6 million dollars was
destroyed along with the hopes of any
sequel never trust the weather so
longest rain or shine all this might
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]